لا تعديل ولا اعاده تفاوض بشان الاتفاق
النووي رساله واضحه وحسمه ارادت طهران
توجيهها للاداره الامريكيه الجديده عشيه
اداء دونالد ترامب اليمين الدستوريه رئيسا
للولايات المتحده فتصريحات ترامب المتكرره
بتمزيق الاتفاق النووي او على الاقل
التوصل الى بنود جديده افضل حسب منظوره
رات فيها طهران مجرد شعارات سيتخلى عنها
الرجل حال دخوله البيت الابيض والا فان
لدى ايران خطه احترازيه جاهزه تمكنها من
استعا ده برنامجها النووي بشكل سيكون
صادما للولايات المتحده حسب ما قال علي
اكبر صالحي رئيس الوكاله الايرانيه للطاقه
الذريه ينضم الينا من طهران الزميل عبد
القادر فايز مدير مكتب الجزيره الذي اجرى
لقاء حصريا مع علي اكبر صالحي سيبث لاحقا
على الجزيره عبد القادر كيف تنظر ايران
الى مستقبل الاتفاق النووي في عهد
ترامب محمود في الحقيقه يمكن القول بان
هذا اللقاء جاء في توقيت حساس نوعا ما
نتحدث عن عام على تطبيق الاتفاق النووي
وكذلك عشيه دخول ترامب الى البيت الابيض
وكذلك في مواضيع اقليميه غايه في الاهميه
مثل مفاوضات الحوار السوري السوري في
استانها فيما يخص ما جاء على كلام علي
اكبر علي اكبر صالحي اليوم فيما يخص
البرنامج النووي وجه رساله حقيقه بشكل
قاطع وصريح ولا لبس فيه عندما قال بان
الاتفاق الفاق النووي الان هو هو لا تعديل
ولا تفاوض بشان البنود لا البنود الفنيه
ولا كذلك البنود القانونيه ولا حتى البنود
السياسيه التي موجوده في هذا الاتفاق اي
ان علي اكبر صالح اليوم يقول للجزيره بانه
لا تفاوض على الاتفاق النووي امام امريكا
امريكا ترامب امامها اما ان تختار ان تقبل
هذا الاتفاق جمله واحده او ان تنقد هذا
الاتفاق بشكل كامل اما التعديل فهو مرفوض
وكذلك التفاوض والجلوس مره اخرى الى طاوله
المفاوضات لبحث بنود جديده في هذا الاتفاق
فهو مرفوض كليا كما قال علي اكبر
صالح كلا نحن غير مستعدين لقبول اي تعديل
الجانب الفني مغلق نهائيا لا يمكن اعاده
التفاوض على اذا ما طرحت مطالب سياسيه ما
مثلا لا يمكن الحديث الان عن قضايا كهذه
لكن الاكيد هو انه لن يكون هناك نقاش او
تفاوض جديد بشان الاتفاق النووي التفاوض
انتهى
وهذا نعم انتهى بالكامل فالعمود الفقري
للاتفاق هي البنود الفنيه من قبيل تخصيب
اليورانيوم ومساله الماء الثقيل ومفعل
الاراك والتفاوض بشان هذه القضايا مرفوض
كليا ولن نتفاوض بشان
الاتفاق سالنا علي اكبر صالحي حقيقه محمود
اذا ما ذهب ترامب ونفذ هذه الوعود وقام
بتمزيق الاتفاق ق النووي ورميه في سله
المهملات كما قال عندما كان مرشحا ل
للرئاسه ماذا ستفعل ايران في تلك اللحظه
علي اكبر صالحي قال بان ايران لديها
سيناريوهات كثيره من بينها السيناريو
الاسوا وهو ان يذهب الاتفاق
النووي جانبا وان يتم نقد هذا الاتفاق
بالكامل وقال بان تمزيق هذا الاتفاق من
قبل امريكا يعني عوده ايران مره اخرى
وبشكل سريع وحاسم الى مرحله ما قبل
الاتفاق النووي وربما افضل اي العوده مره
اخرى الى الجوانب الفنيه تخصيب اليورانيوم
الماء الثقيل مفاعل اراك النووي الذي شكل
اشكالا كبيرا في التفاوض وايران مستعده
لتلك العوده وقال بان العوده ستكون سريعه
وربما تشعر الامريكيين
بالصدمه كما قال علي اكبر صالحي وهذا ربما
يكون الكلام الاثقل الذي ارادت طهران ان
توصله الى ترامب وهو يدخل الى البيت
الابيض هذه الايام
تمزيق الاتفاق يعني ان امريكا ستكون معنيه
بتبرير ذلك للعالم اما نحن فسنعيد
برنامجنا النووي كما كان عليه قبل الاتفاق
وهذا سيجري بشكل يسبب الحيره والصدمه
للامريكيين فنحن لم نهدم الجسور خلفنا
واعددنا انفسنا لاسوا
الظروف الى ما قبل الاتفاق الني نعم
عودتنا ستكون سريعه بحيث يكون برنام جنا
في وضع افضل مما كان عليه قبل الاتفاق نحن
لا نرغب في ذلك ولن نبادر الى نقض
الاتفاق سالنا علي اكبر صالحي بشكل او
باخر اين تكمن المشكله الاساس كان واضحا
بان الاتفاق فنيا على الطريق الصحيح
الاتفاق في المجال القانوني على الطريق
الصحيح المشكله تكمن في العقوبات اي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والعقوبات
التي تفرضها امريكا على طهران من بوابه
المف
في البعد السياسي المرتبط بالعقوبات تكمل
المشاكل فالطرف الاخر لم يلتزم بما تعهد
به ظاهريا هو يدعي التزامه لكن في الخفاء
لم يقم باي شيء ولهذا نرى المصارف
العملاقه متردده في التقدم خطوه واحده الى
الامام بس فقط الطرف المقابل تقصد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الطرف المقابل
نعم هو امريكا هذا اكيد بالطبع لا زال من
الضروري ان تقوم امريكا بتعهداتها مقابل
المصارف العملاقه واعطائها ثقه اكبر لكنها
لم تفعل شيئا البنوك متردده لان امريكا لم
تلتزم بما تعهدت
به كذلك محمود في اللقاء الحصري الذي كان
مع الجزيره اليوم كان علي اكبر صالحي
واضحا عندما قال بان ايران لا تريد ان تضع
الاتفاق جانبا لا تريد ان تكون اول من
ينقض الاتفاق لا ريد لهذا الاتفاق ان يفشل
تريد له النجاح بشكل او باخر ولكنها
تتعامل مع الوقائع على الارض اذا ذهبت
امريكا ابعد من الكلام الذي يتحدث به
ترامب فان لدى ايران كذلك ما تقوله في
المرحله المقبله لا احد يتوقع هنا كما قال
الرئيس حسن روحاني ان يذهب ترامب الى ربما
القيام بما قاله عندما كان مرشحا وايران
تعتقد بان ترامب المرشح سيكون مختلفا
كثيرا عن ترامب الرئيس عندما يدخل الى
البيت الابيض ويت تعامل مع الوقائع بعيدا
عن ما اسماه الرئيس حسن روحاني التخيلات
والاوهام الموجوده في راس الرئيس الامريكي
المنتخب شكرا جزيلا لك عبد القادر فايز
مدير مكتب الجزيره في طهران ومن طهران
ينضم الينا السيد حسن احمان استاذ دراسات
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه طهران ومن واشنطن
باتريك كلاوسن مدير قسم الابحاث في معهد
واشنطن لدراسات الشرق الادنى سيد احمد يان
كان يفترض ب ابرام الاتفاق النووي ان تزول
الشكوك بين الجانبين لكن تصريحات روحاني
وتصريحات علي اكبر صالحي في هذا الاطار
وتصريحات الساسه والمسؤولين الايرانيين
بصفه عامه في هذا الاطار تشير الى حاله
توجس وارتياب في نوايا الطرف الاخر الذي
لم يتسلم السلطه بعد كيف يمكن بناء علاقات
سليمه وصحيه في ظل هذا المناخ
المازو
طبعا مساء
الخير بالتاكيد لايران يعني عندما تذهب
لهكذا اتفاق بهذا الحجم تعد سيناريوهات
بديله وتعد نفسك لاسوا الظروف هذا ما
يؤكده الكثير هنا القضيه انه سلوك ايران
تجاه هذا الاتفاق لم
يتغير وهناك رئيس امريكي انتخب تكلم عن
تمزيق الاتفاق مره او مرتين لذلك يعني من
الواضح انه سيكون هناك توجس وسيكون هناك
ارتياب لانك ان نغط الاتفاق طبعا ستعاقب
وتعلم طهران ذلك لكن اليوم نشاهد انه هناك
نخبه جديده تصل الى سده الحكم في الولايات
المتحده تريد نقض اتفاق دولي وقعته ايران
مع مجموعه من الدول تمثل المجتمع الدولي
لذلك هذا التوجس يطرح و تؤكد ايران انها
ستلج لسيناريوهات بديله اعدتها سابقا ان
جرى تمزيق الاتفاق كما قيل ولذلك طهران
اليوم يعني على تستعد لهذه المرحله
الجديده
وهي اساسا لا تريد العدول من هذا الاتفاق
طبعا تؤكد وجزء من هذا من هذا التوجس
والتصريحات التي سمعتموها اليوم من الرئيس
روحاني والسيد صالحي هي اساسا تقول
للاخرين من مجموعه الخم ئد واحد اي
المجتمع الدولي انه هذه الدول عليها
الاستعداد ي نقد اي خروج للولايات المتحده
نقطه جيده منها هذه نقطه جيده يمكن ان
ننطلق منها بسؤال لضيفنا من واشنطن سيد
باترك كلاوسن هذا الاتفاق ليس اتفاقا
ثنائيا وانما ابرم مع ايران كطرف والطرف
الاخر ضم القوى الكبرى وضم المجلس الامن
الذي تبنى هذه الاتفاقيه وادتها كذلك 100
100 دوله من دول العالم ما مدى جديه ترامب
وتصريحاته بتمزيق هذا الاتفاق والغاء ماذا
في سلطاته لكي يصنعه حيال هذا
الامر ترامب لا يحب هذه الاتفاقيه واذا ما
فشلت
وتمزقت فهذا لن يكون امرا مشكل له بل
سيكون امرا نافعا له ترامب ومستشاروه
يشيرون الى انهم لن يتنصل من هذه
الاتفاقيه مبدئيا بل بدلا من ذلك سيفعلون
ما تحدث عنه ترامب كثيرا خلال حملته اي
تطبيق الاتفاقيه بشكل صارم وايضا التعامل
مع ايران من خلال التفاوض واعاده التفاوض
بشان هذه الاتفاقيه اذا ايران لجات الى
الدول الخمس 5 عده مرات من اجل ان تطلب
اذنا للقيام باشياء لم تكن مسموحه بموجب
الاتفاقيه وايران تزعم بان هذه قضايا فنيه
بسيطه والدول الخمسه زائد واحد وافقت لا
اعتقد ان السيد ترامب بذلك سيكون بذلك
الكرم في الموافقه على طلبات ايران
لتجاهل بعض الاحكام الوارده في الاتفاقيه
بل انه سوف يحمل ايران المسؤوليه الصارمه
الوارده في هذه الاتفاقيه الى اي مدى سييد
حسن احمد ان يمكن ان تقبل طهران بهذا
المستوى من التعامل مع هذا الاتفاق تطبيق
الاتفاق بشكل صارم لكن التلكؤ مثلا في رفع
العقوبات التلكؤ في تطوير العلاقات الى
مستوى اعلى مما هي عليه
الان طبعا بالتاكيد الصرامه في تطبيق
الاتفاق بالتاكيد ايران الان تؤكد على
انها س س هي ملتزمه واساسا ستواجه اي نقض
لهذا الاتفاق من قبل الولايات المتحده اذا
الطرفان ان كان تطبيق الاتفاق بصرامه هو
المطلب الامريكي فايران موافقه عليه اساسا
لا لا يجب ان يطرح هذا الموضوع لكن القضيه
انه هناك يعني الرئيس الامريكي الجديد
تكلم غير مره عن تمزيق الاتفاق يعني انت
رئيس تصل الى سلطه بالتزامات دوليه
للولايات المتحده تتكلم عن نقضها هذا هو
محمل يعني القضيه المحوريه هي هذه ليست
جوانب فنيه طبعا انت عندما تصل الى
اتفاقيه الجوانب الفنيه ما دمت قد اتيت
على
ذكر دمت قد اتيت على ذكر الجوانب الفنيه
عندما يهدد السيد صالح بان لدى ايران
امكانيه للعوده لما قبل الاتفاق النووي
وبنفس الكفا وبشكل يصدم الامريكين هناك
سؤال عن امكانيه ذلك هل هل لدى ايران
القدره الفنيه على ان تنفذ هذه او تمضي في
هذه التهديدات بالنظر الى انها بموجب
الاتفاق تخلت عن
98% تقريبا من مخزونها من اليورانيوم
اوقفت العمل باكثر من ثلثي اجهزه الطرد
المركزي الموجوده لديها فنيا هل تستطيع
ايران تحقيق هذه التهديدات
لا طبعا
هناك سياخذ هذا الامر وقتا لكن ان سارت
ايران على هذا النهج وبالتاكيد بوجود
الخبره التي تراكمت لديها في هذا الاتجاه
تاكيد سيكون الامر اسهل عليها هذه المره
ستكون ايران اقدر على هذا الامر من السابق
بوقت اقصر بالتاكيد هناك طبعا اشكاليات
فرضتها هذه الاتفاقيه والتزمت بها ايران ف
نيا وهذا س سيمدد الم او يطول الفتره
الزمنيه التي قد تصل بها ايران الى نفس
المستوى لكن هذا لا ينفي انه لدى ايران
البن التحتيه لدى ايران الخبره العلميه
ولدى
ايران امكانيات للعوده الى الوراء وهذا
احد البدائل المتاحه لكنه اسوا البدائل
بالتاكيد ا سيد كلاوس سيد كلاوسن يعني ما
مدى الهامش المتاح للرؤساء الامريكيين
الجدد لكي يحدثوا تحولات جذريه في مسيره
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه يعني الرجل
صحيح انه ينتمي للحزب الجمهوري يميني
النزعه لكن هناك في الدول العظمى مؤسسات
تضمن استمراريه على الاقل المعاهدات
الخارجيه هل هذا الامر متوافر في امريكا
هل هناك من يمكن ان يكبح جماح السيد ترامب
عن المضي في ما يعتبر شطط في تصريحاته
الان
في الوضع الطبيعي الاتفاقات الدوليه
يقدمها الرئيس الامريكي للكونغرس للموافقه
ولكن اوباما ادرك بانه لم يكن يستطع ان
يحصل على موافقه لا من مجلس النواب ولا من
مجلس الشيوخ بالموافقه لذلك كافح من اجل
الحصول على الموافقه لذلك هذه الاتفاقيه
تمت بموجب توقيع من الرئيس وهذا كان امرا
خطيرا اتخذه اوباما لان هذا يعني ان
الرئيس القادم يمكن ان يتنصل او ينسحب من
الاتفاقيه بمجرد التوقيع عليها اذا من
المؤسف ان اوباما لم يكن قادرا على الحصول
على اتفاقيه يقدمها ويقنع بها الكونغرس
ونتيجه لذلك فان هذه الاتفاقيه ببساطه هي
اتفاقيه بين جانبين وهي ليست معاهده وليست
ملزمه قانونيا والرئيس القادم له
الصلاحيات الكامله بالانسحاب منها اذا
اراد ذلك ترامب قيل له من قبل المستشارين
بان هذه ليست فكره جيده بان تتنصل من
الاتفاقيه لان بقيه العالم سوف يلوم
الولايات المتحده لانها تنصلت من هذه
الاتفاقيه التي توصل اليها اوباما لذلك
فمن الارجح بان ترامب سوف يدفع قدما وبقوه
من اجل تنفيذ صارم لهذه الاتفاقيه وسيدفع
قدما وبقوه
بشان نشاطات ايران المزعزع للاستقرار في
الشرق الاوسط والخلافات الاخرى بين
الولايات المتحده وايران طيب كما ذكرنا
هناك
توافق بين يعني في هذه الاتفاقيه ليست
اتفاقيه ثنائيه وقع عليها القوى الكبرى
وكذلك قيادتها الامم المتحده واكثر من 100
دوله هل يستطيع هؤلاء وهم حلفاء في
الحقيقه لواشنطن ان يضغطوا على ترامب لكي
يعدل من رايه ومنظوره لهذه
الاتفاقيه
ترامب في خطاباته دائما قال ثلاثه اشياء
اولا انه سينسحب من الاتفاقيه ثانيا سوف
يطبقها بصرامه ثالثا بانه سيعيد التفاوض
بشان الاتفاقيه هذه الامور الثلاثه لا
يبدو بانها تتماشى مع بعضها البعض وليست
متوافقه ولكن هذه هي الصيغه التي يصف بها
ما يريد فعله دائما واعتقد بانه يود ان
يكون قادرا على الانسحاب من الاتفاقيه
ولكنه سيدرك بان هذا ليس الخيار الافضل له
ما لم يستطع ان يظهر بان ايران لم ترتقي
الى مستوى مسؤوليتها بموجب الاتفاقيه سيد
حسن احمدي ان العلاقات بين بوتين وترامب
على ما يبدو علاقات وثيقه او يعني يستلطف
الرجلان كلاهما يعني بعضهما البعض في
المقابل هناك هناك اوجه جديده تتكشف كل
يوم عن خلافات بين موسكو وطهران ماذا اذا
حدث توافق بين موسكو وواشنطن حيال الملف
النووي الايراني واعيد هذا الملف الى
صداره الاحداث مجددا ما موقف طهران
عندها هذا افتراض بعيد كل البعد عن
السياسه الروسيه لانه الى جانب استلطاف
روسيا لترامب هناك علاقات وهناك تعاون
استراتيجي بين ايران وروسيا روسيا تدرك
انه ايران على خلاف الكثير من الدول في
منطقتنا لديها خط
سياسي مستقل سوف لن تقبل باي ضغوطات
خارجيه قد تلجا الى الداخل وقد تذهب الى
الصين وقد تذهب الى دول اخرى ان جرى هكذا
فعل يعني بين روسيا والولايات المتحده لكن
كما اسلفت هذا هذا هذا يعني السيناريو
بعيد كل البعد عن اي ا يعني بالتركيز على
تجربه العلاقات وسابقه العلاقات بين ايران
وروسيا اليوم حسن احمد يان استاذ دراسات
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه طهران كان معنا من
طهران شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفنا من
واشنطن باتريك كلاوسن مدير قسم الابحاث في
معهد واشنطن لدراسات الشرق
الادنا الهجمات التي تستهدف عناصر الامن
والجيش في مصر تتصاعد وتصل مجددا الى
اسيوط حيث قتل عدد من الشرطه في هجوم مسلح
استهدفهم غد عويس تتوقف عند حيثيات الحدث
ودلالته في الملف الثاني من الحصاد